Hallo Leute, das ist unsere neue Serie: Super Easy German.
Das ist so einfach, dass jeder Deutsch lernen kann.
Los geht's.
Wir müssen auch langsam gehen.
Wer ist das?
Das ist Walt.
Wie heisst du?
Ich heisse Walt.
Auf Deutsch heisst Walt - Walter.
Wo kommst du her?
Ich komme aus den USA.
Waw.
Walt ist Matematiker.
Walt, warum bist du in Deutschland?
Ich lerne Deutsch.
Walt, wie alt bist du.
Ich bin 26.
Walt ist 26 Jahre alt.
Walt, welche Hobbies hast du?
Aa, ganz viele.
Jetzt zeigen wir euch Walt Hobbies.
Walt's Hobby ist Laufen.
Walt's Hobby ist Einkaufen.
Walt
kauft ein Eis.
Walt isst gerne Eis.
Walt's Hobby ist mit Freunden abhängen.
Walt hast du Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Toll.
Ich habe auch eine Schwester.
Walt's Hobby ist Gewichtehebben.